Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
Da dieci anni circa, abbiamo avviato
questa pratica nelle Dolomiti
che, sapete, dal 2009
sono "Patrimonio dell'umanità",
bene UNESCO.
Quindi nel 2009, l'uomo ha stabilito
il valore e lo status di questo bene
per l'eccezionale valore universale,
per la qualità estetica e paesaggistica.
Bene: su questo lavoriamo noi,
sulla definizione del concetto
di patrimonio e di paesaggio.
Le Dolomiti sono "patrimonio",
abbiamo definito
con questa parola il loro valore;
però noi viviamo nelle Dolomiti.
Alle mie spalle vedete andare le immagini
dei siti di cui ci occupiamo
da dieci anni a questa parte.
Sono siti molto importanti,
nella storia e nella costruzione
dell'identità dei territori
e dei paesaggi.
I paesaggi, diciamo,
non preesistono all'uomo;
l'uomo deve farli,
deve contribuire a co-generarli.
Questi stabilimenti che vedete
sono ex fabbriche,
stabilimenti produttivi,
o ex scuole, ex colonie alpine.
Tutti diciamo siti, ecco, introdotti
da questa particella dismissiva "ex",
perché non sono più,
sono stati vettori,
trattori del territorio.
Al loro interno si è lavorato,
si è costruito reddito,
economia, socialità, cultura;
e poi si sono fermati.
Ora voi li vedete in una terza fase:
la prima fase è stata
quella della loro edificazione
da parte dell'uomo
che li ha costruiti in seno al paesaggio
e al flusso della storia.
La seconda fase è quella dismissiva:
fine della loro vita
produttiva e propulsiva,
all'interno del paesaggio,
per il territorio.
La terza fase è questa,
perché vi dicevo, da dieci anni
affrontiamo questi nodi irrisolti,
critici e problematici del paesaggio,
ovvero questi grandi siti
che hanno posseduto
un valore molto rilevante
e poi l'hanno perso.
Hanno perso la propria
primigenia identità.
La terza fase è quella del risveglio.
Bisogna capire se siamo in grado
di ripensarne un uso funzionale,
se possono tornare
ad essere utili al territorio,
oppure se non esistono più
perché sono vestigia.
Sappiamo tutto di loro nel passato,
sappiamo poco di loro nel presente,
perché tendenzialmente
non si è più riusciti ad agirli,
e quindi non possiamo
immaginare il loro futuro.
Cosa sono, quindi?
Dei cimiteri che noi contempliamo
guardando al passato, retroversi?
Oppure sono effettivamente patrimonio,
cioè bene, cioè potenziale rigenerabile?
Bene, questa è stata la nostra scommessa:
a due anni dal raggiungimento
di quello status,
abbiamo iniziato a indagare
questi siti, che sono molti.
Le Dolomiti sono sicuramente patrimonio:
ma sono anche un patrimonio
di stereotipi, per certi aspetti,
di cliché, di idee piuttosto banali,
attraverso le quali si vede una montagna
che o non c'è più -
era quella del nonno
con le braghe alla zuava -
oppure è sempre una montagna
che fatica molto a guardare avanti,
a traguardare nuovi orizzonti,
perché è già data.
Ma stiamo dicendo che i paesaggi
vanno generati dall'uomo o rigenerati:
non sono dati per sempre,
alle volte sono dati solo per un periodo.
Bene, nelle prime fabbriche,
nelle prime immagini che avete visto,
che abbiamo affrontato nei primi due anni,
è accaduto questo:
giacevano, dopo aver funzionato
per il territorio,
e poi qualcuno ha provato a muoverle:
sono arrivati degli enti
tendenzialmente pubblici, o anche privati,
e cosa hanno fatto?
Un restauro.
E cosa è successo dopo il restauro?
Che sono rimasti fermi
come prima del restauro.
Cosa vuol dire questo?
Che sono arrivate le risorse economiche,
ma non sono arrivate le risorse vere!
In questo modo il patrimonio
è stato tradito
perché era deficitario
il corredo di risorse
che si tentava di applicare
per risvegliare il bene.
E cosa mancava? Un'idea.
Perché se ti limiti a restaurare un bene,
ma non hai l'idea di cosa ne vorrai fare,
lo tradirai, e farai un male,
che tra l'altro è costato molto.
Bene, con un progetto culturale
ma con una logica funzionale,
perché il test è
anche quello di verificare
se la cultura sia un apparato didascalico,
o diciamo, esornativo.
Oppure se possa essere
un attivatore reale, concreto
e un driver,
una parte della coprogettazione
dei paesaggi e dei territori,
abbiamo affrontato questi siti.
Avete capito, erano finiti
ma non sfiniti a nostro giudizio.
Sicuramente c'era una
grande potenzialità, in questi siti.
Cos'è questa potenzialità?
Considerate che, come state vedendo,
sono straordinari
per valori estetici propri,
per il loro contesto;
poi sicuramente sono fermi,
e forse la cosa che importa di più
è che devi selezionare quelli giusti:
non tutti i siti sono suscettibili
di essere rigenerati e di tornare utili,
devono avere una consistenza logistica,
per usare questa parola pratica,
e quindi ci deve essere un'idea funzionale
nell'approccio e nel tentativo
di rigenerarli.
Cioè, alcuni siti
è meglio non affrontarli,
diciamo che bisogna
soppesarli correttamente;
altri, se valgono davvero molto in potenza
e niente nella realtà,
è opportuno e necessario affrontarli.
È una questione di responsabilità,
e poi anche di sostenibilità, vedremo.
Bene, i siti di cui ci occupiamo
sono solo alcuni non tutti:
non è l'archeologia industriale,
è una selezione ristretta ma ampia.
Abbiamo lavorato su una ventina
di siti dal 2011 ad oggi:
siti, appunto, che valgono
sicuramente moltissimo,
ma nulla nella realtà.
Quindi c'è una ampia misura da colmare.
Perché se di un sito diciamo tutti
che vale molto, vale 100 -
qui siamo nell'ex villaggio Eni
di Borca di Cadore
che fece il Signor Enrico Mattei
negli anni Cinquanta,
con l'architetto Edoardo Gellner
anche insieme a Carlo Scarpa in una parte,
se diciamo che vale molto
ma non vale niente nella realtà,
vuol dire che noi
non riusciamo mai a risvegliare
il potenziale di questo sito.
E a cosa serve il suo potenziale?
Al legittimo proprietario?
No, tutti i siti hanno
un legittimo proprietario,
pubblico o privato;
ma come ora state vedendo
il forte di Monte Ricco a Pieve di Cadore,
poi rivedrete il Vajont -
i siti che scegliamo sono talmente forti,
formidabili ed eccezionali,
da essere o esemplificativi
di temi più vasti di loro stessi
o veramente, diciamo,
bisogna essere ciechi
per non vederne il potenziale.
Allora il loro valore di patrimonio
è di tutti, non solo dell'ente
che ne possiede la fisicità.
E su questo lavoriamo noi:
con un progetto di responsabilità e riuso,
lavoriamo per riprendere
il valore patrimoniale,
in senso culturale,
di questo bene, per tutti.
Cosa possono tornare
a essere, questi siti?
Dipende.
Dai primi casi, delle fabbriche
che avete visto nelle prime immagini,
sono tornati a essere fabbriche.
Cosa abbiamo fatto?
Li abbiamo approcciati.
Erano falliti.
Abbiamo costruito una serie di relazioni.
Abbiamo quasi 500 partner.
Chi sono questi partner?
Sono partner territoriali
ed extra territoriali,
pubblici e privati, imprese, aziende,
partner scientifici o della ricerca.
In sostanza si compie un grande momento
di attivazione di reti territoriali
ed extra territoriali
e si cerca di far di nuovo vedere
l'appeal e il potenziale dei siti.
È un po' come avere un gran cesto
di frutta eccezionale in cucina,
ma la luce spenta.
Nessuno mangia la frutta che va a male,
è sufficiente accendere la luce.
Non è facile "accendere la luce"
in un sito che è fermo da anni o decenni,
dove, diciamo, la società particolare,
in quel contesto peculiare,
ha perso speranza.
Tutti la perderebbero:
prima funzionava,
poi non ha funzionato più,
poi l'abbiamo restaurato
e ancora non è andato.
È un maledetto inghiottitoio?
No, è una risorsa
che bisogna rimettere in rete.
Come fai a metterla in rete,
se non accendendo le reti?
Prima si parlava di dopamina,
ricordate stamattina?
C'è un saggio del '74, mi sembra,
di un neuropsichiatra, Oliver Sacks.
S'intitola "Awakenings", "Risvegli".
Si parla di malattia, letargia, e di cura.
Io sono un curatore.
"Dolomiti Contemporanee" è un progetto
di cura e curatela
del paesaggio, del patrimonio.
Serve la dopamina culturale,
serve un'iniezione,
serve una neuro-trasmissione.
Serve insufflare la fiducia
nei territori che l'hanno persa,
per riaccendere loro stessi.
Questi siti appartengono
a questo territorio che li contiene:
ma poi sono talmente importanti,
vedete il Vajont,
che superano ampiamente
la propria collocazione geografica
in seno al territorio.
Il punto è che sono esclusi
dal flusso della storia.
Sapete cosa è successo nel Vajont,
il 9 ottobre del '63?
Non sono morte 2.000 persone,
sono morti un po'
tutti gli uomini della Terra.
Quindi quel luogo è lì e non è lì.
È di tutti gli uomini della Terra.
È un luogo emblematico,
è al tempo stesso un luogo particolare,
collocato in un punto dello spazio-tempo,
e un luogo universale.
Per cui riaccendere la scuola,
la vecchia scuola elementare
chiusa dal Vajont
e farne un centro
per la cultura contemporanea
della montagna e del paesaggio,
vuol dire affrontare un sito spento,
terribilmente spento,
perché il Vajont per certi aspetti
è la terra dei morti viventi:
è un luogo dove c'è una diga
che richiama ogni anno
migliaia e migliaia e migliaia di persone,
che tendenzialmente vedono
una lapide, un muro del pianto.
Affrontare questo paesaggio,
non volendo ammettere il fatto
che esso possa coincidere
con il paesaggio della tragedia,
questo vuol dire tradire gli uomini.
I paesaggi sono per i vivi
che li devono costruire.
C'è una definizione di Edoardo Gellner,
il realizzatore dell'ex Villaggio Eni,
cioè del programma sociale
di welfare di Enrico Mattei
e di molte altre cose,
Gellner dice che
"Il paesaggio è la sommatoria
di ambiente naturale e azione dell'uomo.
Buona azione, buon paesaggio;
cattiva azione, pessimo paesaggio,
non un luogo per l'uomo".
Dunque il Vajont non può essere
un paesaggio dimenticato, retroverso,
ostaggio di una tragedia
che c'è stata e non c'è più,
o paralizzato nella memoria,
che può essere anche un patogeno.
Perché non consente, se non la elabori,
di prefigurare il paesaggio,
altro paesaggio, paesaggio proiettivo.
Nel Vajont è necessaria
una situazione proiettiva,
per cui se venite a vedere cos'è
il nuovo spazio di Casso
è un presidio culturale
che si oppone alla predatoria egemonia
di una tragedia che non può essere
l'identità dei vivi di oggi.
Non c'è dimenticarsi,
non c'è assenza di memoria:
c'è una visione che vuole restituire
questi siti agli uomini,
che sono coloro che li hanno fatti
e poi li hanno persi.
Bene, tutto ciò si fa come vi sto dicendo:
in ogni sito si realizza una residenza,
vengono artisti, anche architetti,
designer, paesaggisti,
economisti della cultura,
scienziati, filosofi.
Viene Marc Augé,
che abbiamo portato nel Vajont,
come a Borca di Cadore
a riflettere su questi luoghi,
altro che non luoghi!
Ma siamo in grado
di riproiettarli nel presente
in modo utile o no?
Sì, credo, nel momento in cui riusciamo
non a suggestionare una platea,
ma convincere il territorio
che quella è roba sua,
che può tornare ad essere utile.
Nel Vajont bisogna vivere,
l'ex villaggio Eni di Borca di Cadore
può servire a molte cose,
non serve a se stesso.
Questi siti non bastano a loro stessi,
non centra quanto belli
o importanti sono stati.
Non bastano.
Serve un'azione vigorosa dell'uomo.
È deliberata, l'azione:
a noi nessuno ci ha obbligati.
Io lavoro con una trentina
di ragazzi giovani, del territorio,
che vogliono fare qualcosa
per il territorio,
e quindi affrontiamo i siti.
Attraverso le strategie delle reti
attiviamo il territorio,
di cui siamo il reattore, diciamo.
Convinciamo il territorio
a riprendere fiducia
in un'impresa del rilancio.
Per questo abbiamo 500 partner,
dal territorio e da fuori il territorio,
ce ne sono molti di internazionali,
molti di nazionali,
molti di locali, grandi e piccoli.
Tutti indispensabili, anche perché noi
non abbiamo i soldi.
Vi ricordate prima?
Erano venuti i soldi senza le idee.
Non era patrimonio, non era risorsa.
Poi arriviamo noi, senza i soldi
ma con un patrimonio di idee,
e i siti ripartono.
I primi siti sono ripartiti,
sono entrate attività
commerciali e produttive
perché hanno riscoperto
la logistica intelligente di quei siti,
non erano affatto morti.
Alcuni siti sono più importanti di altri
perché "pesano" di più,
nel volume fisico, storico,
nel valore estetico e così via,
come l'ex villaggio Eni,
dove torniamo tra poco.
Lì si attivano
piattaforme più strutturali,
come nel Vajont.
Non vai a riaprire
una fabbrica nel Vajont,
abbiamo dovuto vivere due anni nel Vajont
e farci capire dagli abitanti:
potevamo essere gli ultimi stupidi
o cannibali, invece no.
Per quello che ho detto prima,
ragioniamo in una logica
di funzionalità pubblica, non privata.
Non ci sono egoismi
dei curatori o degli artisti:
tutti concorrono e fanno un pezzo
del programma di rilancio.
E questo non tradisce l'arte,
che è sempre se stessa.
Solo che l'artista è intelligente,
sensibile, ingegnoso,
è un enzima, attiva processi,
non si accontenta
di definizioni né di sentenze,
per cui per lui il sito non è morto:
contribuisce a rigenerarlo.
I siti diventano cantieri
della produzione artistica e culturale,
dove si innescano le reti,
anche perché portiamo le genti
molto diverse tra loro.
Ci sono gli scienziati della foresta.
Sapete cos'è la tempesta Vaia?
Quattordici milioni di alberi
portati giù dal vento, Ottobre del 2018.
Se venite nei siti che state vedendo,
in particolare a Casso,
e al forte di Monte Ricco,
trovate delle mostre collettive
di arte contemporanea
con 30 artisti che lavorano
su temi di Vaia,
insieme a scienziati del clima,
della foresta, biologi, chimici.
Quindi l'arte non fa una caprioletta,
non è l'apparato esornativo,
è parte del meccanismo
della strategia di rigenerazione.
I siti ripartono, dunque,
e li mettiamo anche
nelle piattaforme a disposizione.
Tornando a Borca,
sapete che da un po' di tempo
ci siamo guadagnati le Olimpiadi
del 2026, Milano-Cortina.
Si dice che hanno da essere sostenibili.
Sono sostenibili se non costruisci
dell'architettura nuova
e ti sai responsabilmente render conto
di cosa c'è già a disposizione.
Il Villaggio Eni di Borca
sono 100 mila metri quadri
costruiti molto bene
perché c'erano Mattei e Gellner.
Non c'erano limiti di spesa
ma soprattutto di ingegno.
Quello è uno spazio
su cui dobbiamo spendere
considerazioni serie.
Lo riprendiamo o no?
È fatto talmente bene
che non è un rudere.
È vicino a Cortina,
non è una logica antagonista:
Borca o Cortina.
Le Olimpiadi, d'altro canto,
non sono le gare di sci del 2026,
sono un'opportunità di sviluppo
per il territorio da qui a lì.
E quindi occorre, ancora,
prendere il patrimonio
e rinsavirlo, e ritrovarlo.
E anche, se diciamo sostenibilità
e basso consumo di suolo,
veder quel che c'è,
prima di fare del nuovo.
È semplice.
Diceva una cosa il signor Mattei,
diceva che "l'ingegno che accomuna
gli scienziati e gli artisti,
è la capacità di vedere cose
dove non le vedono gli altri".
Occorre essere orbi per non vedere
il potenziale di questi siti, credo io.
Quindi non basta vederle -
e in effetti Mattei non si limitava
a vedere: faceva molto.
Se questi siti valgono
davvero molto in potenza, come diciamo,
vanno visti e poi vanno fatti.
Dobbiamo costruire i paesaggi
della contemporaneità,
lo sguardo del contemporaneo è questo:
non è nostalgico,
non è retroverso, vi dicevo.
Cerca di proiettare
i propri potenziali avanti:
non immemore del dietro, avanti.
Questa è una cosa che va considerata,
dobbiamo capire se noi siamo
effettivamente in grado
di risvegliare questo patrimonio,
o se ci accontentiamo di dire
che le Dolomiti sono
patrimonio dell'umanità,
senza poi entrare
all'interno del territorio
a vedere cosa possiamo davvero fare
con le nostre armi -
la cultura, la sensibilità
e l'intelligenza -
per riattivare questi siti
a favore di tutti.
(Applausi)